welcome everybody my name is Professor
Brian Keating and I am the proprietor of
the Dr Brian Keating into the impossible
podcast and YouTube channel so we're
going to be doing this every so often
impossible questions segment and I hope
you'll enjoy it and you'll send in
questions to the Instagram and or
Facebook group drinking Bros nerds and
other uh sessions that we can access and
I will read the questions and I'm
probably quarterly basis and we'll
hopefully get some really stimulating
answers and questions back and forth uh
viewer a Rizzoli asks is the speed of
light a set speed or can light waves
themselves be manipulated or sped up or
slowed down uh that's a very good
question we don't believe that there's
any way to transmit light or any other
immaterial or material particle or field
or Force faster than the speed of light
which is 186 000 miles per second and
there's no way to actually speed it up
in fact when Einstein showed in the
early part of the 1900s was that even if
you were traveling at close to the speed
of light and you turn on a flashlight
that flashlight will still be have
photons within it that will move at the
speed of light you would think that
you'd get basically twice the speed of
light but it's possible to show through
the mathematical Transformations that
are known as special relativity that he
invented uh that that speed of light is
a constant in fact it's such a strongly
held belief that no information no other
forces are field or our structure can be
communicated faster than the speed of
light effectively nowadays the speed of
light is a constant that's defined in
other words it's a number that we Define
to be measured at a certain value with
no uncertainty in it and then everything
else can be measured with respect to it
distance time Etc uh and so no there we
don't believe that light waves
themselves can be sped up or slowed down
in a vacuum now you can speed up or slow
down light in a medium and that's how
glasses work they diffract by slowing
down differential waveform of the light
as it propagates through a medium that's
not the vacuum but I assume that you are
asking about the propagation speed
possibility of speeding it up faster
than the speed of light C 186 000 miles
per second that is believed to be
impossible but you can slow it down in
fact some scientists have slowed it down
to effectively a walking speed but again
this is using materials that are
engineered here in a laboratory uh thank
you very much for tuning in to this
episode of impossible answers with yours
surely Dr Brian Keating Chancellor's
distinguished professor of physics and
co-director of the Arthur C Clarke
Center for human imagination at the
University of California San Diego check
me out my YouTube channel Dr Brian
Keating subscribe to my podcast the into
the impossible podcast please leave
ratings reviews and all that that really
helps me out and we'll do more of these
hopefully like once a quarter we'll
compile your questions and I'll
hopefully give you some answers to
Impossible questions for now signing off
and thanking you very much for being a
part of my Multiverse this is yours
truly Professor Brian Keating